bientôt c'est ce plaisir à écouter
aujourd'hui se trouve sur greipel un jeu
de rock à la s'écoule dans ma cuisine
l'aps blu-ray pas encore prêt on s'en
bat les steaks ce manoir et l'héritage
de mon grand père cette maison est une
longue histoire
c'était mon abri mon refuge c'était tout
pour moi depuis que je suis née jusqu'à
ma mort oh tu t'es déjà réveillé savent
ils pleurent nous on est sam c'est ça on
et le mans ont fait tout ce qu'ils
pleurent l'actuel manche de la peine de
la peine je voi l ol mais qu'ils
achètent ou olala il fait peur on est
scorpion portel pour marseille 4e geek
et dentelle comme moi où je suis qui
êtes vous ou tu es tu es mon invité est
ce que tu vois 7h je l'appelais joseph
le bébé serait intéressant moi j'appelle
mon frigo carlos le potager oh la la il
parle beaucoup l'art donc pantalon on
connaît bien ce genre de méchant là il
m'a dit qu'il paraît ghz et sa hache et
quand il reviendrait bras contre ado
d'histoire cool alors je préfère qu'il
me tue avec sa hache que d'écouter
d'autres histoires de spike use mouse
the move caméra excellent jeu derrick
prochainement dans le jeu le plus triste
monde doit alors est ce qu ont réussi à
s'enfuir enfuis toi rien mais qui
borderont couach est prévue plus tard
est ce que à voilà ils y arrivent à
temps mais ce n'était pas attaché je me
suis mais tranquillement super oh la la
il a poignardé un fauteuil trois
couteaux comme ça et on m'avait de
partir avant qu'il fasse le même avec
nous alors en fait le jeu au niveau
gameplay il m'intéressait parce qu'il a
l'air de bien ressembler ap pointé point
péter abbas a regardé ça c'est lui qui
va nous être utile s'allume quoi le
courant ça fait rien à l'eau ça fait
rire amical on s'en va là des valves à
et l'a logiquement du coup ça va faire
une explosion avec des étincelles
non
ils arrivent ils arrivent ça devrait ça
va péter
excusez moi oui ça devrait être très
troublant pour vous ça va là et là on se
bat donc on s'en fout oh là là mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça vous savez
c'est hyper beau en plus on est vraiment
pété le crédit aux mondiaux la porte
s'ouvre droit vers moi un rapace ça il a
même fait un don au passage une arène y
passe elle a même fait un doigt au
passage bref ces partis y aller on va
pas on s'en fout des bruits on n'a pas
le temps voilà là et c'est super joli
sans déconner longueur c'est
l'incroyable angers reçoit ces flaques
d'huile glissé mme cassez l'adulte ce
serait le plus belle mort qu'une mourir
sous les coups de hache deux mecs au
monde une échelle on va la prendre
on s'enfuit dans les tréfonds de la map
alors on dira rien sur ce [ __ ] c'est
une démo on remonte
ok on entend des bruits bas il ya des
flashes mais j'aime ce qu'on essaie de
me faire du bien de lui dati ou étant
des images subjective là oh là là non
mes mecs c'est autre chose tu verras
faut jamais aller de là où d'où ils
viennent
ok à tolo les bâtards il retrouve un
petit coup imposer pour eux et nous on
est obligé d'aller là dedans la se fait
pas penser à péter un peu là c'est quoi
cet arrêt du nom imec adore et le méga
les arrivées comme ça chez lui quoi
jeter test appartement c'est
l'appartement le plus glauque du xiiie
arrondissement le pire de tous olala
mekas une faune est épars toi mec peut
pas ouvrir les portes un os non je serai
préféré qu'on puisse pas y akouala ya
rien d reste d'humain dans des sacs
poubelle sûrement c'est quoi ça iliad il
ya plein de deux balles à ces fermes et
je trouve la clé on va la trouver
oui c'est quoi ce point il ya un truc
qui grattent bordel mettez de l'huile
mettez de la gav gendarme et un truc
c'est quoi ça c'est fermé
arrétez arrétez arrétez [ __ ] tu chies
dans mon froc là c'était quoi
yako non mais tu pas ko
moi j'ai toujours rêvé de gagner surtout
les crocs c'est que des médias ou les
pois les châteaux les poils
tu sens bon [ __ ] vous avez dû avoir
encore plus peur vous voyant mavericks
ou pas bonjour tu ne veux pas mal hein
hein tu ne veux pas de mal c'est quoi ça
c'est la renier c'est la reine et qui va
nous sauver est fait sur nos yeux voient
plus rien d invincible comme les enfants
oh là là je suis dans un look où l'on
voit bien c'est tout noir
voilà un écran noir allons on perd le
camionneur respawn
mais le même but l'idée que la plagne
histoire à raconter ils s'en sont les
seuls selon la ville et s'il va t elle
mute
mais vous savez quoi ça se trouve
j'étais obligé de mourir pour
déverrouiller la porte qui était fermé
juste là la merde au maire de bus
exactement ce que je veux dire je suis
désolé pour toi pauvre homme
ok on est là des quoi il ya un truc la
hyène armes ni larié machette led
zeppelin car il ya une arme il ya un
fusil à pompe ou non la ya un couteau
n'ont d'ailleurs sabres n'ont d'ailleurs
tabarot string
puisque je peux pas fermer cette porte
je suis obligé de revenir en arrière
parce qu'elle bloque le passage donc on
va revenir en arrière un lien pour
ouvrir sa mairie mais qu on a un journal
écrit en russe où on va pas pouvoir lire
malheureusement n'y a rien et pourquoi
y'a plein de trucs à ouvrir alors qu'ils
aient jamais rien voilà là avait un
temps d ici là ça c'était fermé avant
mais oui hélas d'avoir la clé la clé de
la porte qui nous qui nous emmène
ailleurs à elle est là allure allait
soulever le coussin
ça tombe souvent entre le pardon c'est
quoi ça attendez voir sur la chance
n'était pas qu'à cocher là avec une
tronçonneuse ou la porte est fermée
[ __ ] c'est médias scripté bordel c'est
encore plus stressant ce qu'en plus
récents qui soit ballester jean et la
france entière et courageuse face à ce
désastre ce désordre ce démon ceux des
terres j'en ouvre toi ou au toit et y
arriver à bien la clé c'est sûr qu'avec
les la regarde et on vous voir tous ces
[ __ ] de paccar champions ulysse ça
comme un enfant aulas y à la clé
on se barre bien cordialement il est pas
là c'est bon à vérifier l'intégralité
des coins on a vidé l'historique on à
vider le cache est désactivé les cookies
ça ne veut rien dire mais c'est une
manière de se rassurer c'est ça que ça
veut dire n'est ce pas et saison ben là
c'est super bien travaillé ça m'énerve
j'aurais préféré tomber dans la rue est
barrée au courant ohlala mais pour m e
poèmes dits fermés trouve une clé j'ai
pas essayé doit cette porte
mais ok défi relevé challenge axelle red
alors ça n'a plus ouvrir voilà j'ai
décidé je lance un mouvement aujourd'hui
vraiment voté pour moi je décide
d'interdire l'ouverture de placard ça ne
sert à rien il ya une petite pièce
étroite avec un bain très bien alors je
vais plus jamais vous faire visiter le
piège cette maison sans de questions au
lit sans de l'eau j'ai lu dans son reer
ou avoir peur ok respawn elle va tuer
m'a tuer sans domine noire
il arrive et prouve bien que les noirs
cap cime en brasse c'est scandaleux quoi
alors on va là-bas au montage moi
j'appelle état je préfère aller vers la
petite pièce un peu glauque un peu
étroite
je change d'avis maman et l'allemand
j'attendais cette page web
c'est sûr qu'il ya rien de mieux que de
monter les marches vraiment pour aller
dans sa salle de bains j'adore qu'est ce
que c'est que ce bordel un an au nom au
nom
c'est glauque j'aimerais que la lumière
revienne au mans [ __ ] c'est vrai enfin
dans le dos parce que quand je veux
quelque chose c'est ce qui se passe quoi
oh là là on monte jusqu où mon gars du
reun fille bien en basset à personne
j'ai une fille bien aussi à personne je
vais rien derrière moi c'est à personne
mais tu packard est un nom ne dit pas je
dois tourner son arrêt km heure je veux
pas monter ah ah ok on est ce normal
quoi
allez je vais dans la petite porte
étroite et blogueur lequel il a glissé
un cadavre vont pouvoir passer entre les
deux troupes inde
non non tu arrêtes de volée devant moi
je ne m'accrocherai pas de toi ça peut
durer des heures à se faire [ __ ]
bon bah écoutes je ne me sacrifier allez
viens me couper la gorge aie aie aie n'a
pas le temps c'est un homme qui n'a pas
le temps il s'en fout il vole il me
traverse c'est un fantôme gentil après
tout c'est vrai on juge sans trop savoir
c'est abstiennent h et qui a du sang
partout par terre qu'il est méchant et
non et voilà jean slim fast cette vidéo
j'espère sceau de la plus ces cas
n'hésitez pas et menez 2 comme
d'habitude il était extrêmement
stressant ce petit jeu et oui c'est déjà
la fin j'ai coupé comme ça parce qu'en
fait la démo n'est pas terminée donc là
on a accès à l'étagé tout mais voyez en
haut des marches si un mur invisible qui
nous fait bien chier les bras mais qui
ne sera plus là quand tu ne seras plus
qu'une simple démo là je crois que ça
faisait longtemps que je m'étais pas
autant chie dessus sur un jeu d'horreur
l'ambiance est là c'est incroyable
j'adore cet effet deux le mec tu vois
les fois des fois tu le vois pas ne sait
pas trop à quoi t'attendre à chaque
petit recoin de la maison mais ça va
regarder aussi transformé attendant une
prochaine vidéo peut-être la prochaine
fois dans le bureau et ce serait bien
puisque l'on aime la cuisine
à la limite il faut vous servir de lomé
mais rien de plus chuck norris
fin